Fans sharing video reactions to movies, TV, and trailers.
[mock Star Wars theme MIDI]
(boom)
Chris Stuckmann: Oh!...the hell was that--
(machinery sounds)
Whoa! Oh, I'm so sorry, I don't know what's happening, I'm sorry, I mean, it won't stop--
(boom)
Nostalgia Critic: Stuckmann! Are you stopping the opening crawl again?
Stuckmann: Whoa! Critic, Snob, what are you guys doing in space?
Cinema Snob: Well, we just wrapped up our Force Awakens review.
Critic: As well as just celebrated HRRRAAnukkah!
Stuckmann: Well, I just finished doing my Rogue One review with you.
Continuity-wise, I don't think those timelines sync up.
Critic: No no, I'm pretty sure our two separate storylines match up exactly, pretty sure.
Snob: Yeah, it only FEELS like two years have gone by.
Critic: Yeah, and we all look exactly the same as when we saw each other a couple seconds ago!
Stuckmann: Do we? I'm pretty sure at least my teeth look different.
Snob: Yeah, so step off the crawl so we can review The Last Jedi!
Stuckmann: I don't know, if literally no time has passed, I don't think the crawl is gonna give us much.
Critic: Look, this is how these Star Wars movies work.
A few years pass by with each one and the crawl always catches us up!
Stuckmann: I'm tellin' ya, Critic, they got nothing.
Critic: Well, we'll be the judge of that, so step off!
[Star Wars MIDI resumes]
Critic: God damn it!
Stuckmann: Yeah, I told ya the crawl's pointless. They got nothin'.
Critic: Alright, let's just get on with it.
Snob: Oh wait, I always wondered what the last lyric was.
Snob: Meow! Lloyd was right!
Critic: *sigh* Let's just get going!
Stuckmann: How did you guys do that?!
Critic: Chris, there have been huge advances in the last couple of seconds since we saw each other!
Snob: The Force, space technology, appearing wherever you want, all big breakthroughs.
Critic: And we have those ingenious minds to thank for it!
(porg noises)
Stuckmann: Porgs? They're responsible for all this?
Critic: Well, whatdja think, they were just a toy ad named after Swedish Chef gibberish?
Snob: Shame, Stuckmann. Shame.
Critic: The porgs are the most im-porg-ant part of Star Wars right now, they're even more central than the Force!
Stuckmann: I mean, I like 'em fine, I just didn't realize they were so interwoven into everything.
Critic: They are.
Snob: Extremely interwoven.
Critic: Now let them continue to figure out the mysteries of the universe while we start our review.
Stuckmann: Man, I am so sorry again, porgs.
Snob: They'll forgive you, Stuckmann. In time.
Critic: This is our review of The Last Jedi a.k.a.
A Porg's Tail.
The Last Jedi is Episode VIII of the Star Wars whatever-gy.
It was highly anticipated obviously, but also carried a lot of concern.
Snob: After complaints that its predecessor, Force Awakens, was a retread of A New Hope,
fans were worried whether or not this would be a retread of Empire Strikes Back.
Stuckmann: They were also concerned it might be slightly underwhelming like many parts of its spin-off, Rogue One,
so this film had a lot to live up to and several hurdles to jump.
Critic: But thankfully the porgs pulled us through!
Critic: Unlike some naysayers that doubted!
Stuckmann: I'm sorry, I didn't know.
Snob: Shame, Stuckmann! Shame!
Stuckmann: STOP SAYING THAT!!
Let's see how Last Jedi did with...
The Last Jedi.
Snob: Shame!
Stuckmann: After an impressive space fight on par with Rogue One--
Critic: All it was missing was Darth Vader ceiling-ing someone to death!
Stuckmann: --General Leia escapes with the Resistance, angering General Hux but especially angering Emperor-ish Snoke.
Hux: Lord Snoke, I assure you my hammy overacting will not be thwarted next time,
please don't use your Force--
Snoke: --to do this?
Hux: *yelp*
(slam)
Snoke: Yeah, not feeling it, buddy. Think you'd have your stuff together after our planet-destroying eight ball blew up.
Hux: I understand, your Snokiness, but we have a way of tracking them through lightspeed!
Snoke: Oh, that's cool.
You'd think, me being so powerful, I'd sense that.
Hux: Or maybe read the report on your desk every once in a while--
*yelp*
(slam)
Snoke: No, I got apprentice shit to do.
Speaking of, where's that douchebag from Girls?
Hux: *scream*
Kylo Ren: Hey-hey.
Snoke: Three things.
Kylo: Go.
Snoke: Kill your mother.
Kylo: Got it.
Snoke: Ditch the pointless mask.
Kylo: Gone.
Snoke: And do a shirtless scene for the ladies.
Kylo: You have watched Girls, right?
Snoke: Unwillingly.
Kylo: Girlfriend?
Snoke: Of course girlfriend!
Critic: Kylo Ren finds he can't destroy his mother, but luckily the other fighters can, blasting her into space.
Stuckmann: I'd be lying if I said this wasn't a little awkward, considering this is Carrie Fisher's last movie.
Critic: Oh, don't worry, it gets even MORE awkward!
[mock Superman theme MIDI]
Snob: Oh, c'mon, Critic. Show what really happened.
Critic: That IS what really happened, she goes shooting star on our asses!
Even if you overlook Fisher's passing and the fact that we're watching her cold corpse come back to life--
Snob: That's a pretty BIG overlook!
Critic: --when did Leia learn to do something like that?
Stuckmann: We see how hard it is for prodigies Luke and Rey just to move rocks.
How can she vacu-suck her way back to the ship with no practice?
Snob: Maybe Luke and her were getting a drink one night and he said
Luke: So, if by some rare chance, you're out Sandra Bullock-ing in space, just remember
hold your hand out to the nearest ship.
Force has got your back.
Leia: That's uncomfortably specific but good to know.
Luke: Welcome to my world.
Snob: It's weird!
Critic: Meanwhile, Rey is still in the midst of
handing Luke Skywalker his lightsaber.
Rey: Master Skywalker, I've journeyed far and wide to--
oooookay.
Snob: Luke tries ignoring her, but the big walking carpet is a little more forceful.
Luke: Chewie, what are you doing here?
Luke: I told you, I'm not a Jedi anymore.
Critic: Rey brings Luke up to speed with all the things that have happened since he's been gone.
Luke: So Han gave up these sequels to do Blade Runner sequels...
that was a smart choice.
Rey: Show me the ways of the Force, then
you can come back with me and restore balance.
Luke: No, I'm happy here with my weird lizard nuns,
my green nipple alien milk, and of course, the porgs.
Rey: My God, you have porgs here?
Luke: Yes, they have taught me more about
the Force than I ever thought possible.
Stuckmann: Okay, did they 'cause I don't remember that happening!
Critic: I can't believe you missed how im-porg-ant they are!
Snob: Listen to him not, marshmallows of enchantment.
SHAME!
Luke still says no, but R2 shows him his frenching sister,
which gives him the motivation to train again.
Critic: Meanwhile, Hux is still chasing down Leia's ship, but due to some confusing techno-jargon, they can't defeat them yet.
Hux: Tell me again why we're not firing at them!!
First Order Personnel: They're too out of range!
Hux: But they can't even go to lightspeed!!
First Order Personnel: No, they'd run out of fuel!
Hux: Then why don't we go a little faster than they're going?!?
First Order Personnel: Look, we only have three settings on this ship. Do you want evil or efficient?
Hux: Well, evil, of course!
Snob: While Leia is out of commission,
the second-in-command, Vice Admiral Holdo--
boy, that would have been a different movie!
(pop)
--is put in charge, and she seems less like an admiral
and more like a working mom trying
to keep her cool around her teenage son.
Poe: We need some answers, we need to know what's going on!
Holdo: I hear you, but I need you to trust my decision.
Poe: How? How can we trust you if we don't even know what you're doing!?
Holdo: I need to keep things from you, so that you can learn a lesson.
Poe: We don't need to learn any lessons, what we need to do is--
Holdo: GO TO YOUR ROOM!
Poe: You're the worst vice admiral ever!
Stuckmann: This brings us to Finn, who just woke up from his kinda coma,
and Rose, a technician who lost her sister in battle.
Finn: Rose, you know about space engineering.
How are they tracking us even though we use lightspeed?
Rose: It must be that new porg technology that's changing the world!
(smack)
Stuckmann: OW!
Rose: There's a code breaker who can help us.
We can sneak to the solar system he's at,
bring him back, and he can hack the other ship.
Finn: Great, let's go!
Rose: You coming?
Critic: U-U-Um...w-we're good.
Snob: All fine.
Stuckmann: Thanks though.
Rose: Are you sure? It's really exciting!
Finn: Yeah, we got space horses and everything.
Stuckmann: Probably not as exciting as you'd expect.
Snob: Yeah, I'm getting a "sidequest filler" vibe.
Critic: Tell us how it went though.
Finn: Come on...
*exclamations of protest*
*loud groaning*
Critic: Alright. Let's talk about this scene.
Stuckmann: Finn and Rose are fine characters,
but their subplot feels unnecessary and not very Star Wars.
Critic: They go to a surprisingly boring casino where the code breaker is,
but a lot of the time, it's just listening to them say
Rose: I was raised here among the people,
abused to make the system of greed work...
Social commentary social commentary social commentary...
Finn: ...social commentary?
Rose: With political subtext!
Finn: *sharp gasp*
Snob: Remember the pointless diner scene in Attack of the Clones
and the pointless squid scene from Rogue One?
Just combine those scenes together
and you have one-fourth of your movie.
Stuckmann: What's unfortunate is that every time it cuts back to Rey and Luke, the story becomes so challenging and mythical.
Luke: I knew Snoke had already corrupted Kylo's mind.
For a split second, I thought about killing him.
(lightsaber activation sound)
But then, I was like "y'know, nah".
But then, he happened to wake up at that exact moment.
So...yeah, all of this is kind of because a poorly-timed light switch.
Rey: My God, let's continue to explore this and develop our
Finn: Us again!
*more heavy groaning*
Rose: We freed some animals.
Finn: Space horses!
Snob: ...great...
Finn: Oh, and we found the code breaker,
but he was busy and didn't do anything.
Rose: In fact, you can probably start a pointless MacGuffin count around now.
Stuckmann: Awesome. Can you let us get back to Luke and Rey again?
Finn: Oh! Sure.
Rose: *chuckle* Silly us.
Rey: Why would this strange section of the island be associated with the Dark side?
Critic: Well now, this should be interesting...
Rey: Perhaps because it could give me answers to my past,
and the way of the Jedi is letting go of your past.
What a fascinating conflict of--
Finn & Rose: Drag! Drag!
Snob: *loud groan* Dammit!
Stuckmann: Haven't you dragged ENOUGH?!?
Rose: We found another code breaker!
Finn: This is DJ.
Oh God, is that what we call you?!
DJ: Yep. I'm a rogue who always plays on the winning s-s-s-side.
Critic: Is that supposed to be a stutter?
DJ: Yeah, but it's pretty inconsistent. Just like this movie, am I r-r-r-right?
I'm gonna be the most utilized cameo since Gwendoline Christie.
Stuckmann: Rey decides to go to Kylo Ren,
because she feels there's still good in him,
while Luke is thinking about burning what's left of the Jedi Texts.
He gets an unexpected visitor though.
???: Wazzup, L-dog?
Luke: Back off, Master Yoda. I'm gonna destroy the Jedi tree temple thingy. At least, I think I'm going to...
Yoda: Less schlock, more shock.
(thunder)
(explosion)
Snob: WHOA! I completely underestimated Jedi ghosts!
Stuckmann: Talk about becoming more powerful than you can possibly imagine, that muppet don't mess around.
Critic: You always thought the Jedi spirits were more of a guiding light, giving advice and wisdom.
With that kind of power, you can have a friggin' Jedi ghost army like in Return of the King and win this war in two seconds!
Yoda: We must let go of the past and create a future of new challenges and ideas.
Luke: You DO know you're talking to Star Wars fans, right?
Yoda: Bite my ass, they can!
Luke: ...fair enough.
Snob: Back on Holdo's ship, Poe takes over command by forcing her to surrender.
Holdo: This is mutiny, Mr. Poe.
Poe: That's right, we're taking over. We're finally gonna put things the way they should be!
I'm tired of listening to you, I'm tired of not getting all the answers, I'm tired of d-
is nobody having a problem with me holding a gun at you and taking over the ship?
Holdo: Yeah, no, everyone seems fine, doing their own thing.
Poe: Yeah, I kinda thought there'd be a lot more resistance in this Resistance.
(blaster fire)
*grunt*
Poe: General Leia???
Leia: Well done, Holdo. You got us to the planet where we can evacuate our fleet.
Poe: Wait...so this was all part of your plan!
Holdo: Yup.
Poe: Well, why didn't you just tell us before?
Holdo: ...well...
...like I said before, to teach you a lesson.
Poe: What, not telling anyone the plan and risking a mutiny; that LITERALLY just happened!?
Holdo: Well...*unintelligible sounds*...
Poe: Was that gibberish?
Holdo: No...that was an alien language.
Poe: What does it mean?
Holdo: IT MEANS SHUT UP!!
Stuckmann: Kylo Ren takes Rey to Snoke and
WHAT IS UP WITH THAT PLAYBOY MANSION ROBE?!
Critic: Yeah, Snoke is looking less like an intimidating villain and more like a crumpled-up drawing of Quagmire.
Snoke: Rey, baby, welcome to my pad! Do you like my Snoke-ing jacket? I am totally gonna rule the universe.
Snob: Granted, the CG on him is a lot better than in the last one,
but some of this material is a little too on-the-nose familiar...
Snoke: Let me show you your friends as they perish in space.
Let me loosen your cuffs because that's proven to be smart in the past.
Let me...
...make this a little easier.
Page 84, scene 5.
Rey: Where you reveal there's no more good left in your apprentice.
Snoke: Yeah...page 92, scene 7.
Rey: Where you reveal that you've tricked me and you're more powerful than me.
Snoke: Got it...and page 103, scene 12.
Rey: Where you reveal you're going to kill me,
but then your apprentice stabs you in the back!
Snoke: Right on it.
oh wait, skip that o--
OOOH!
Who the hell even was I? Would it have killed anyone to give me one sentence of backstory?
???: Oh my God, Frank! That's, like, the second time we let the leader of the Dark side get killed!
I'm beginning to think the red guards are cursed!
Frank: Ehhh. It's okay, Harry. Revenge is afoot.
Harry: Right!
(radio static)
Send in every stormtrooper ya got, nyehehehe!
Frank: Uh, Harry. What are you doing?
Harry: I'm going for backup.
Frank: No, Harry. We got this.
Harry: I really feel like we don't!
Frank: Uhhh, you think more guards would have saved our emperor?
Harry: Very much, yah.
Frank: No. We use our ninja moves with no blasters, ehehheh.
Harry: Uh, I don't know, that, uh, that sounds very wrong.
Frank: It feels so right.
Harry: I think this is why we have two emperors on our dead list.
Frank: Harry. We're the red guys.
When has anything ever gone bad for a guy wearing red in sci-fi?
Harry: Eh. Guess you're right. CHARGE!
Frank: Charge.
Frank: Ow.
Harry: Heheh, we really suck at this.
Kylo: Rey, come with me. Together, we can page 92, scene 4 of Empire Strikes Back.
Rey: That is my favorite page, but I can't!
I know my parents were a bunch of nobodies who abandoned me.
Kylo: Not really sure what that has to do with...
wait, what?
Snob: Hang on, if her parents are nobody, why was the last movie building it up like they were somebody?
Rose & Finn: MacGuffin number two!
Snob: Oh...um, what a twist, I guess.
Critic: Speaking of weird surprises, after it's revealed that DJ switched sides--
DJ: Tr-Tr-Tr-Traitor.
Rose & Finn: MacGuffin number three!
Critic: Yeah, great,
BB-8 saves the day by gunning down everyone, operating a killer robot!
Stuckmann: BB-8 weirdly has a body count...
Critic: Thus Finn and Phasma have a big fight that's been building up for a while.
Phasma: Time to finish what we sort of started!
Snob: Unfortunately, it's cut short because Holdo sacrifices herself
by aiming her abandoned ship at the First Order and putting it in lightspeed.
(time distortion)
Holdo: Oh, hey, guys! 'S my last words. Crazy, right? *giggle*
(sonic boom)
Phasma: Is that all I get?!? I'm Gwendoline goddamn Christie!!
I'm fifth least likely to die on Game of Thrones!!!
Finn: Sorry, we had to cut it short.
Phasma: For WHAT!?
Finn: For boring casino FILLER!!!
Phasma: LAME!!!
(explosion)
Finn & Rose: MacGuffin number four!
Finn: We need real surprises in this.
Rose: Right?
Critic: Hux finds Kylo Ren unconscious and tries to finish him off.
Hux: It's the end of the line for
yooooooou've got something right there, on your shoulder, ju-just there.
Kylo: I'm in control now. Let's go destroy the Resistance.
Hux: Cool beans...!
Snob: On the planet below, the Resistance are cheerfully reunited--
Leia: There. I hugged him. Ya happy, ya weirdos?
And Greedo shot first.
OHHHHHHHHHHH
Snob: --doesn't last long, as the First Order sends in the AT-AT Walkers.
Stuckmann: Isn't it pronounced "at at"?
Snob: There's gonna be enough bullshit in the comments, why worry now?
Finn: Oh no, a laser battering ram!
Poe: A what now!?
Finn: It's...exactly what it sounds like.
And i'm gonna sacrifice myself to it.
Poe: Yeah, I guess it did kind of explain itself.
Stuckmann: Finn tries to sacrifice himself to destroy the laser, but Rose stops him at the last minute.
Finn: Rose! Why'd you do it, Rose!?
Rose: It's not about fighting the things we hate, it's about saving the things we love.
Stuckmann: So you sacrificed yourself to stop him from sacrificing himself.
Snob: Yeah...either way, someone's getting sacrificed.
Rose: shhhh!
Stuckmann: ok
Rose: Save the things we love, Finn...
Now take my middle school kiss!
*kiss*
Finn: Um, is that the kind of relationship we had?
'cuz honestly, I think I had more chemistry with Poe.
(radio static)
Poe: (on radio) Hey, thanks a lot, buddy!
Now, bring her back and be sure to keep it vague whether or not she's dead.
We don't know if she's sequel material yet.
Rose: HEY!
Finn: Oh, c'mon, you're set for life with conventions!
Stuckmann: Luke Skywalker arrives though and sees his sister one last time before facing Kylo Ren,
allowing the Resistance time to escape.
Kylo: Don't even try and toy with me, Skywalker!
I can see right through you.
Luke: shit-- Oh.
Kylo Ren, I have come to apologize for failing you.
Know that even if you were to blow me to smithereens,
you would only increase the pain that you feel
(explosions and laser cannon fire)
Hux: Ha, look!! Operation Blow Him to Smithereens was a smashing success,
you can even ask him yourself!
*shriek*
Kylo: AAAAAAAAAAAA
Stuckmann: It turns out Luke has used all of his powers to project himself from entire planets away!
Luke: Haaaahahahaha! You think this is the real Quaid!?
Stuckmann: But it drains all of his literal life force.
Snob: He strikes a Captain Morgan's pose and fades into the sunsets,
allowing Rey to rescue the Resistance while he distracts them.
Stuckmann: This will likely be polarizing for some fans,
but here's a few reasons why I don't mind it.
It shows that both Luke and the Force are continuing to change and evolve.
That's what we want from our myths, isn't it? To evolve?
What if, after A New Hope, fans said "the Force can't shoot lightning",
or "the Force can't make you see ghosts",
or "the Force can't lift an entire ship"!
We would miss out on an ever-developing and ever-changing world that was being shaped and molded,
so in my opinion this is a great and even practical addition to what the Force can do.
Snob: Y-Yeah, but he was projecting the dice the whole time too?
Stuckmann: What?
Snob: While he's fighting from galaxies away killing what's left of him,
was he really just sitting on that rock saying to himself
Luke: Remember the dice, remember the dice, remember the dice, remember the dice.
Snob: That just seems like a weird detail he would focus on.
Stuckmann: Snob, who do you think taught him how to do that?
(porg noises)
Snob: My God, I've questioned the porgs and brought shame to all...
Stuckmann: Whoa! Whoawhoawhoawhoawhoawhoa!
Critic: Nonononononononoheyheyheyheyhey!
That is not the porg way.
(porg noises)
Critic: Oh, it is? Okay, continue.
Nah, nah nah nah, y'know...Han's died enough.
Snob: Fine.
Critic: Finally, we see one of the abused kids from the casino look out into the stars,
imagining all that the future holds for him.
Stuckmann: And yes, he even appears to be Force-sensitive.
Snob: Last Jedi my ass! This movie should have been called
[Archer imitation (probably Rob)]
Critic: And that was the latest Star Wars movie. How was it?
All three:
AMAZING!
except when it was kind of dumb.
Critic: The more I think back to it,
the more I do find things wrong with it,
but, at the same time, the more I think back to it,
the more I don't care.
Because I'm so distracted by how visually grand
and emotionally breathtaking the other scenes are.
Snob: It has flaws, certainly, and for some, they might be too distracting, but it still feels like Star Wars.
Even though it's not going in a completely different direction,
it's still going in a direction that's different enough to be entertaining.
Stuckmann: It borrows from more than just from itself, it borrows from classic myths, anime, religions, and philosophies.
It still knows how to keep us talking
and asking questions, looking for deeper meanings, which is what any timeless myth should do.
And I'm still looking forward to seeing what's gonna happen next
in a galaxy far, far away.
And after all this...I just gotta say...
thank you, porgs, for making this all blossom.
(porg noises)
(blaster fire)
Snob: Okay, seriously. I did not like those things.
Critic: Same.
Stuckmann: Alright, but, uh...who's gonna fly the ship?
Critic: C'mon, how hard could it be?
Snob: So I'll see you in Mexico?
Critic: Yeah.
Stuckmann: See you there.
Harry: That sounds very wrong.
Frank: It feels so right.
Hey, Doug Walker here doing the charity shout-out.
For those have been paying attention,
we did a charity stream not long ago
for St. Jude Children's Hospital Research
and we're keeping that video open and donations open for a little bit.
If you go to our YouTube channel, you can see where the charity stream video is
and we're still having the donation link open for a few more days.
That's what the charity is gonna be this week
and if, by the time you see this, it's, y'know, gone,
maybe you saw that sometime later, still donate!
It is a wonderful organization,
It's one of those charities where, y'know how you kinda do research and certain things and then you find out stuff like "Oh, I didn't know that",
This is one of those charities were the more research you do, just the cooler stuff you find and they just do so much wonderful, phenomenal stuff.
and, yeah, it's just definitely worth checking out and so, definitely for the charity stream that we did, definitely consider going over there and donating.
And even if the charity stream, if the link is gone by the time you watch this, please consider giving anyway because they do such wonderful, phenomenal work
Definitely check it out if you get a chance, and thank you so much! Take care.